- I said to myself when I started
1000AwesomeThings.com
I will never do it for money.
I never put an ad on the website ever.
50 million hits it's only cost me money
through URL renewing.
There's something, a model
I call the 20 for 20 Challenge.
Motivation doesn't actually
lead to action like we all think.
Action leads to motivation.
There's these three numbers that
scare me every single morning I wake up.
I think about these numbers everyday.
I'm a writer, speaker,
and entrepreneur.
I'm best know for writing
The Book of Awesome,
and my TED talk, The 3 A's of Awesome.
My new book is called
The Happiness Equation.
It shares the nine simple secrets
we can all do everyday
to live happier lives.
I'm Neil Pasricha.
I'm here with Evan Carmichael.
Here are my top 10 rules for success.
(dramatic music)
Let's go all the way back to 1932
when on a peanut farm in Georgia
a little baby boy named
Roosevelt Grier was born.
Roosevelt Grier, or "Rosey" Grier
as people used to call him
grew up and grew into
a 300 pound, six foot five
linebacker in the NFL.
He's number 76 in the picture.
Here he is pictured with
the fearsome foursome.
These are four guys in the L.A. Rams
in the 1960's you did not
want to go up against.
They were tough football players
doing what they love
which was crushing skulls,
and separating shoulders
on the football field,
but Rosey Grier, also,
had another passion.
In his deeply authentic self
he also loved
needlepoint.
(laughter)
He loved knitting.
He said that it calmed him down.
It relaxed him.
It took away his fear of flying.
Helped him meet chicks.
(laughter)
That's what he said.
I mean, he loved it so much that
after he retired from the NFL
he started joining clubs,
and he even put out a book called
Rosey Grier's Needlepoint for Men.
(applause)
It's a great cover.
If you notice, he's actually
needlepointing his own face.
What I love about this story is that
Rosey Grier is just such
an authentic person, and that's what
authenticity is all about.
It's just about being you,
and being cool with that.
I think when you're authentic
you end up following your heart,
and you put yourself in places,
and situations,
and in conversations that you love,
and that you enjoy.
You meet people that
you like talking to.
You go places you've dreamt about,
and you end up following your heart,
and feeling very fulfilled.
My mom is from Nairobi, Kenya.
My dad is from Amritsar, India,
so they were immigrants to Canada.
When they grew up they said,
Neil, it's real simple.
You do great work.
Then you have a big success,
and then you be happy.
It's the kind of
classic parenting advice.
Sometimes, I ask people
have you heard this advice
before you've given it?
Everyone's like, yeah,
that sounds normal.
You study hard then you get good grades,
and pretty soon
you become a doctor, right?
- Right.
- Or you work really hard,
and in the corporate environment
you get promoted and then you're happy,
but the model I actually like
to put forward is reverse of like
a profit focus model,
and instead it's happiness focused,
so like I said
it's not great work to big success
to be happy.
It's the happy leading to great work
leading to big success.
What do I mean by that?
I mean if you as a leader can invest
in your employee's happiness,
and well-being at the beginning
then we know from all kinds of research.
(mumbles) did an incredible study
based on the book
The Hell of Happiness.
It shows that your
productivity goes up 31 percent
if you're in a sales based role
where many people are
sales goes up 37 percent,
creativity goes up three times.
This is from just being happy,
and then what happens afterwards
you have the big success at the end.
I'm talking about career success.
You're more likely to get promoted
if you're in a good place at work,
and you have a positive mindset.
Also, you live longer.
You live about 10 extra years,
so zooming out from profit.
Ignore that for a second.
If you actually want those variables,
productivity, creativity, sales
out of your employees
the biggest investment you can make is
on their happiness at the front side.
There's something, a model I call
the 20 For 20 Challenge.
The 20 for 20 Challenge.
What I'm trying to say is
if you can commit for
20 minutes a day for 20 days in a row
to do a small, simple happiness exercise
that you can invest
in yourself at the beginning.
What are some examples?
Not all of these,
you just pick one, okay?
It's a 20-minute brisk nature walk,
or it's a 20-minute journaling exercise,
or it's a 20-minute meditation,
or it's committing
a conscious act of kindness.
(mumbles) with somebody.
Bring a flower for somebody, right?
Or writing down five gratitudes.
Any of those five, remember,
the nature walk,
the journaling exercise,
the meditation,
the random act of kindness,
or the five gratitudes will invest,
and convert your positive mindset for
the remainder of the day,
so if you are a boss,
or you're an employee
where's that 20 minutes?
I guarantee everyone's saying,
yeah, I got to like kind of
scoot to this meeting at lunch,
or maybe, maybe people say like,
you know, I've got to
go grab a sandwich, or something,
but very few people say,
I've got to go meditate,
or I really need to like
commit my random act of kindness,
or go do my journaling exercise.
It's not part of our conversation yet,
but yet if we can make
20 minutes of investment in
our mental health and our happiness
then we tip over our brains for
the remainder of the day,
and everything else goes up.
Like you said it's
the service profit chain,
not a new concept,
but from 20 years ago
we've always known that
happy people at work perform better,
and as a result your sales,
your profit, everything else lifts.
- A meaningful work
seems to be something
that you seem to suggest is
a very common way that
people can find happiness.
- Yeah.
Oh, man, I have a really
passionate view on work.
Basically, I went to high school
in Whitby, Ontario.
Thank you.
- Yeah, Whitby's in the house.
- That was a lot.
There was one woo at first,
and then the whole Whitby
school bus erupted.
Anyway, we had a guidance counselor
at my high school
who everybody was in love with,
and he was awesome.
He high fived teenagers in the hallways.
He was one of those guys that
everybody could approach,
was accessible to everybody, you know,
and we have mandatory retirement.
Age 65, the moosh.
You were
given this sort of like
passage to pension.
We had the ceremony at the school.
It was like the Mr. Holland's Opus,
you know, ending.
The next week after that
he had a heart attack and died.
You know what when I tell that story
you know the reaction I usually get
it's that, oh,
and it's also, you know, that happened
to a brother-in-law of mine,
or my grandfather also retired,
and then he just wasn't the same.
You hear that more often,
so I look into this
concept of retirement.
Here's two things I find out
that are interesting.
Number one, Fortune Magazine says
the two most dangerous years
of your life physically are
the year you were born.
Infant mortality over
the entire lifespan of
the human race is 40 percent, okay?
That's kind of a big number.
Better now, but 40 percent.
Number two, the year you retire, okay?
Big deal.
The New York Times reports that
the incidences of depression spike
40 percent in that year you retire,
so I started looking around the world
at this concept of work,
and of leaving work,
and ceasing to work.
Here's what I find.
Dan Buettner,
and National Geographic did
study on the Blue Zones.
Some of you may have heard of it.
It's the places around the world
where people live like
way longer than we do.
He studied a place called
Okinawa in Japan where they live
on average seven years longer
than in North America,
and guess what they call retirement?
Nothing, they don't even have
a word for retirement.
Literally, nothing in their language
describes the concept of stopping work.
Instead they have a word which I love
called Ikigai, I-k-i-g-a-i,
Ikigai which roughly translates as
the reason you get out of bed
in the morning, okay?
What is your Ikigai?
So I gave my wife two little cards
at Christmas last year.
We put them on our bedside tables.
She's an elementary school
teacher at the TDSB.
She writes to educate leaders
who make a difference in the world.
I write finish writing this book,
or, you know, to increase
happiness inside organizations,
or whatever I'm focusing on,
but it gives you a bit of direction.
It gives you a direction,
so I advise and I recommend
you never retire plus
just to throw in there
retirement was invented, okay?
It wasn't like we used to do this.
We invented it in 1889 in Germany
when Chancellor Otto von Bismarck
just arbitrarily said,
hey guys, retirement age 65,
and life span was 67.
Now we all want to retire earlier,
and we live way longer,
so those years
can be vacuous,
and they can be troublesome
for all the reasons I mentioned,
so I advise people to have an Ikigai,
and to find work that
includes the four S's.
Social fulfillment,
the structure of getting
out of bed in the morning.
The stimulation of always
learning new things,
and the story of being part of
something bigger than yourself,
something you couldn't do by yourself.
If you have those four S's
then you have what I call
meaningful work.
- If you're not doing
the work that you love
how can you tap into that
sense of purpose,
and meaning, and joy?
- Great question,
and I'm not advocating that
someone about to punch out of
30 years in the meat packing plant
sort of punch in for 30 more years.
I'm not saying that.
What I am saying is that we all have
168 hours in a week, okay?
You have that many,
I have that many,
Justin Trudeau has that many,
Mark Zuckerberg has that many,
Warren Buffet has that many.
The richest men in the world
can't buy more time.
It's the one thing that's not for sale,
so if you take 168 hours in a week,
and you divide it by three
you get three buckets of 56.
56, 56, and 56.
If you are lucky enough
to sleep eight hours a night,
and with two small children I am not,
but if you are then
that's 56 hours a week, okay?
If you work 56 hours a week
as whatever job you don't like, okay?
That might be your middle bucket,
however, I would still argue that
those two buckets justify,
create, and pay for your third bucket
the whatever you want to do bucket.
Is that where you volunteer?
Is that where you're
in the church group?
Is that where you're doing
something you love?
Even when the meat packing plant
is over, or the gig is done
then your bucket can expand,
and you could keep doing work.
The definition of retirement I'm using
is ceasing work completely,
becoming idle, okay?
- Yeah.
- Many people who are like on retirement
they're like I love retirement.
I volunteer at the hospital.
I'm always at the library, and I do...
You're not retired.
You're doing 100 things, okay?
So that's what I'm saying.
It's like keep finding things you love.
How do you handle setbacks?
That's a great question,
and, sometimes, people say like
do you have setbacks?
Like, yeah, lots, I mentioned,
I kind of joked at the beginning
I'm like there's tons
of failures in there.
The thing is, you know,
if you ask a good photographer
how do you take such good pictures?
Do you know what most of them say?
I just take lots.
You've heard this before.
It's like I just take thousands,
so that's why I always get 10 great ones
because I take so many more,
and like I think it's like a table
with legs on it.
That's your life.
If you have a table like this
with one leg on it,
and I know because I was here before,
and I knocked it over.
It can fall over.
It can fall over pretty easily.
I call that one table.
You can think of it in terms of
it's up to you.
Cashflow streams if you want.
Relationships if you want,
but for me it's like
how many legs does your table have?
So how do I handle setbacks?
I try to have a multi-legged
table at all times.
Like I said, at Walmart
I was doing my blogs on my books.
It made me more risk-taking
in my writing to know
I had a full-time job.
It made me more risk-taking in meetings.
I was mouthy and asking
questions of the CEO
'cause I'm like, yeah, fire me,
I got this other thing.
You know what I mean?
That's two legs on my table.
Two legs right there,
and then if I add a third thing,
a passive income stream,
or I'm doing something online,
or I'm speaking now, whatever,
it's multi-legged.
How do I handle setbacks?
I look at the other legs.
I think about what else I got going on,
let that thing naturally come back,
it's okay.
Just be doing multiple things at once.
To me that's how I think about it.
It never makes a low feel super low
because I'm not all in on anything.
The secret to turning your biggest fear
into your biggest success.
I'm embarrassed to admit this,
especially, because we're filming this,
so it's going to be on YouTube forever,
but I'll say it right now
for the first time.
I didn't know how to swim
at all in my early 30's, okay?
I'm 36 now,
and why didn't I know how to swim?
My sister could swim, and everything.
It's because I had ear infections
my whole childhood,
so I had tubes in my ears
and I had a traumatic experience
on top of all that
when I fell into the pool,
and I couldn't swim.
I can almost still see it today,
so that's fine
because you know what?
Who cares I don't need to swim.
I live in Toronto.
There's no ocean, I'm good.
I wouldn't even bring my
bathing suit to the pool party.
My friends would want to
go swimming at university
I hang out with the treadmill,
no problem.
I eliminated swimming from my life.
You see, I didn't think I can do it.
I didn't think I had
the capability to do it,
and I certainly didn't want to do it,
you know, I had no motivation,
so I never did it,
and that's how we think
about anything, right?
You got to have the capability,
then the motivation,
and then you have the action.
I never got to do because
these things were never going to happen.
All that changed on
my second date with Leslie
when she said to me
over dinner one night.
"So, do you like swimming?"
I was thinking to myself,
oh-oh, play it cool Pasricha.
You don't want to scare her off,
and I said to her, nah.
Play it cool.
No, I'm not really a big fan.
She says, "Ugh,
"that's too bad.
"You see, my family's had a cottage
"on an island for generations,
"and there's 20 of us up there
"the whole summer.
"My 80-year-old grandparents.
"My five-year-old cousins.
"We get up every morning in the summer
"jump into the lake,
"and swim around the island.
"It takes about half an hour.
"Man, I guess you can't come."
Suddenly, that night
without thinking about whether
I can do it, or whether
I want to do it I just did it.
I signed up for adults
learn to swim classes at
the City of Toronto downtown pool.
I don't know how many people here
have seen the downtown
City of Toronto pool
this isn't a recommended thing to do.
It's like, you know, right, you know,
right in the urban center of the city.
I'm like getting my life jacket,
the goggles, the whole thing.
I'm walking onto the pool deck
that first Wednesday night.
My heart is beating louder
than it had in years.
I was so nervous,
but you know what happened when
I walked in on that pool deck, Rachel,
I get out there, I get out there,
and you know who's out there?
A whole bunch of people
who suck at swimming.
For once I'm not the only one.
People are from landlocked countries.
They had more traumatic
experiences than me.
Trust formed very quickly.
So we get into the shallow end
with the flutter board,
the life jacket, the goggles,
and within five minutes of doing that
where I could touch the bottom
I was like, hey wait a minute.
I can do that.
Like that's not hard I can do that,
and then you know what?
The next week I wanted to do it.
I wanted to do it
because I was like, well,
I kind of thought I can do it now,
so the next week I was like
flutter kicking in the deep end.
The week after flutter kicking
with no life jacket.
By the end of the eight weeks
I was doing the front crawl.
The thing I realized is that
motivation doesn't
actually lead to action
like we all think.
Action leads to motivation.
It's completely flipped.
You want to write that novel.
You don't need the perfect coffee shop,
the right idea,
and the expensive moleskin.
Just write one sentence with
a pen from the hotel on a Post-It note.
Just doing that will tell you
that you can do it,
and then you'll want to do it.
You want to run a marathon?
Forget the good shoes,
the right place, and the running buddy.
Forget it.
Just run to the stop sign
in your dress shoes.
By the time you do that
you're like I can do that,
and then you think you can do it,
and then you'll want to do it.
It's the exact opposite.
Don't just take it from me.
You guys are scientists.
You probably trust someone
like Issac Newton, you know.
He's the greatest physicist
of all time after all,
I mean, up there with Einstein.
The guy discovered gravity,
invented calculus.
Pretty good resume.
He'd probably be hired
at Google these days.
He actually said
in his first law of motion like
I can remember like grade 10 science.
An object in motion
will remain in motion
unless acted upon by
an equal or greater force.
Put another way
if you start doing it
you place action first you'll continue.
It's harder to stop,
and that's why at the end of
my adult learn to swim classes
I signed up again,
and I signed up again,
and it was the same exact class.
I didn't go to learn to swim two.
I just did learn to swim one.
I'm like I love this, it's amazing.
I can do the front crawl.
I loved it so much I just kept
doing it over and over again.
It is easier,
it is easier
to act yourself into
a new way of thinking,
and then to think yourself
into a new way of acting.
Our brains are often the enemy.
How do you do it?
How do you make your biggest fear
into your biggest success?
You just do it.
You put action first.
We all know Nike's slogan Just Do It.
Well, you probably don't know is that
Nike was an $800 million company
with low 20 percent market share
when they came up with this slogan.
Then they struck a nerve
deep inside of us
something we all believe is true.
You know what?
On the heels of the slogan
$10 billion company,
50, 60 percent market share.
That's over the lifetime
of using the slogan.
We can remember the ad that jazzed you up.
You're like I can do that
just get out there and do it,
and it works, it works.
Look, we're all going to get lumps,
and we're all going to get bumps.
None of us can predict the future,
but we do know one thing about it,
and that's that
it ain't going to go according to plan.
We will all have high highs,
and big days, and proud moments of
smiles on graduation stages,
father-daughter dances at weddings,
and healthy babies
screeching in the delivery room,
but between those high highs
we may also have some lumps,
and some bumps, too.
It's sad, you know, it's not pleasant
to talk about, but you know
your husband might leave you.
Your girlfriend could cheat.
Your headaches might be
more serious than you thought,
or your dog could get hit by
a car in the street.
It's not a happy thought,
but your kids could get mixed up
in gangs or bad scenes.
Your mom could get cancer.
Your dad could get mean.
There are times in life when
you will be tossed on the well, too,
with twists in your stomach,
and with holes in your heart,
and when that bad news washes over you,
and when that pain sponges,
and soaks in I just really hope you feel
that you've always got two choices.
One, you can swirl and twirl
in gloom and doom forever,
or two, you can grieve,
and then face the future
with newly sober eyes.
Having a great attitude is
about choosing option number two,
and choosing,
no matter how difficult it is,
no matter what pain hits you
choosing to move forward, and move on,
and take baby steps into the future.
I have a really strong
viewpoint on advice,
and it's a bit counterintuitive,
and maybe sometimes controversial.
The thing is there's a famous quote
from the 1800's that says
when we are asking for advice
we're really looking for an accomplice.
We're almost always looking for
someone to either agree
with what we want,
or disagree with it,
so we can kind of
stand firm in our viewpoint.
You ask people what you
should name their kid,
or what school you should go to.
You might already have
an idea in your mind.
One day I was surfing
through the newspaper.
I noticed the cover of
The New York Times,
and the cover of The Toronto Star
the biggest two newspapers
in both countries had
the exact opposite advice on them.
One said no need to get extra Vitamin D
'cause there's been a study,
and 1,000 people have been in the study,
and all the research says
you don't need more Vitamin D.
The other newspaper said
go on the advice to get your Vitamin D.
None of us are getting enough.
The earth is tilting away from the sun,
like, guys, this is a big problem.
I'm like it's like huge,
credible news sources
with studies backing both of them
on the front page the same day
showing the exact opposite advice.
I started thinking about advice
the concept of advice,
and started realizing that
the most common advice of all
is actually cliches.
- Right.
- So true that you just
have them memorized,
and it's like, you know,
the early bird gets the worm,
but when you start thinking about it
you're like or is it good things
come to those who wait, you know,
and you start thinking, okay, well,
it's actions speak louder than words,
or is it the pen is
mightier than the sword.
For every single cliche,
or piece of advice you ever heard
there is an equal opposing
pice of advice,
so the biggest advice
I'll leave anybody with
don't take advice.
The answers are all inside you.
You already know what to do,
and anything you're seeking
is just trying to confirm something
you already believe.
Forget it, you don't need the books,
you don't need the newspapers,
you don't need any advice,
you already know what to do
just do that.
I'm 36 now, when I was 20 years old
I was going to Queen's University.
Anyone went to Queens here in this room?
Oh, a lot, good Queens turnout today.
This is good.
I was writing for the campus
humor newspaper Golden Words.
It was free, like it wasn't
a paid job, but I loved doing it,
and I loved writing this
comedy writing stuff,
so I took a little paid internship
down in New York City
writing for a comedy start-up.
Simpson's writer,
Saturday Night Live writers
living in the Lower East Side.
I was like this is my dream,
but it turned into
the worst job I'd ever had, why?
Because once I got paid to do
something I loved naturally,
suddenly, I had constraints.
I had to write an article
about this topic
with this person by this time,
and it became so debilitative,
like limiting and I said to myself
when I started 1000AwesomeThings.com
I will never do it for money.
I never put an ad on the website ever.
50 million hits it's only cost me money
through URL renewing,
you know what I mean?
It's never made a cent,
so I was smart about that.
I was smart about focusing
the intrinsic motivator of
doing something you love,
but I was really dumb about
starting to focus on stat counters,
best seller lists,
those extrinsic motivators
kept creeping in,
and you know what the problem is, Rachel?
They creep into our lives all the time.
- Right.
- You can get a job for
a place you love, cool.
I'm working for a company I believe in.
Pretty soon you have a job evaluation.
You have a salary.
These are extrinsic motivators,
and you start targeting your behavior
to hitting like
I want to be a solid performer.
That lowers your performance
because you're like
I just need to get somewhere
in the middle,
and I get my crappy two percent raise,
like I don't really get much from that,
and if they're going to reward me on that
then the studies all show that
those extrinsic motivators
actually block you from seeing
your intrinsic motivators,
so Dr. Teresa Amabile
at Brandeis University
showed that if you have girls
teach piano to other girls,
and you say do it because you love it,
and you want to teach them piano
they do an awesome job.
If you say we'll give you
a movie ticket if you teach piano
for half an hour they stink at it.
They get frustrated.
They leave after half an hour
like they're just not very good,
so it could be that paying,
or communicating a numerical value
for something actually reduces
your own internal motivation,
so when The Book of Awesome took off
I got hooked on all that stuff
because it's so visible,
so tangible, so real,
and to answer that question
for myself with The Happiness Equation
I drew a new model called
The Success Triangle.
I say there's three kinds of success.
There is sales success.
There is social success,
and there is self-success.
Sales success.
How many books did you ship?
Like how many products did you sell?
How much money did you
make from something?
Social success.
What do other people think?
What's the critical review?
Is it nominated for an award?
Is there a prize associated with it?
If it's a movie does it get
an Academy Award?
Then self-success
how do you feel about it?
They can contradict,
they contradict like
Hotel Transylvania 2
won a ton of sales, right?
And zero Academy Award nominations.
Spotlight which won best picture
had $19 million at the box office
compared to over $200 million
for Hotel Transylvania 2.
Why do I know those numbers?
Because they contradict all the time,
so the only way to solve it
is to answer it for yourself,
and focus on self-success like
I wrote a letter to my unborn child.
I hope he gets to read it one day,
and if I can try my best
to keep focusing on that mantra
then it absolves me from worrying about,
or at least stressing over
things I can't control.
I love hanging out with three year olds.
I love the way that they see the world
because they're seeing the world
for the first time.
I love the way that they can stare
at a bug crossing the sidewalk.
I love the way that they'll stare
slack-jawed at their first baseball game
with wide eyes and a mitt on their hand
soaking in the crack of the bat,
and the crunch of the peanuts,
and the smell of the hot dogs.
I love the way that they'll spend hours
picking dandelions in their backyard,
and putting them into a nice
centerpiece for Thanksgiving dinner.
I love the way that they see the world
because they're seeing
the world for the first time.
Having a sense of awareness
is just about embracing
your inner three-year-old
because you all used to be
three years old.
That three-year-old boy
is still part of you.
That three-year-old girl
They're in there and being aware
is just about remembering that
you saw everything you've seen for
the first time once, too,
so there was a time when it was
your first time ever
hitting a string of green lights
on the way home from work.
There was the first time you
walked by the open door of
a bakery and smelled the bakery air,
or the first time you pulled
a $20 bill out of your
old jacket pocket and said found money.
There's these three numbers that
scare me every single morning I wake up.
I think about these numbers everyday.
Number one, 147.
This is the average amount of
emails people receive a day today.
147 is the average number of emails
the average person
is currently receiving.
150, this is the average number of times
an average person checks
their cell phone a day,
which means three times
you check you cell phone
there's nothing there
because 147 times there's an email,
but three times is like, yeah,
I need to check that.
Number three.
The average person is making 295
decisions a day.
295 decisions a day.
Did you have lunch where I had lunch?
Do I want the beef?
Do I want the chicken?
Do I want the fish?
They all look good.
Which one do I choose?
Where do I sit, who do I sit with?
There's so many decisions.
You're making decisions all the time.
I mean, I'm driving to work,
and I'm making decisions.
What street do I want to turn?
Left, right, here, there.
You get on the treadmill
hill, manual, incline.
What do I want to watch on the TV?
You're making too many decisions,
and this decision-making energy
in our brain is a finite resource.
We only have a limited amount of it,
and when it's gone it's gone.
You don't even notice you're using it,
and there's only two ways
to replenish it.
Number one is sleep,
and number two is glucose,
or anything that turns
into glucose in your body
which means at the front of
the supermarket when you're just
done choosing 30 different salsas,
and 20 different kind of eggs.
It used to be that there was
one kind of eggs, but now there's 20.
When you're done choosing your
eggs and your salsa you get to the front
what is there?
Piles of candy bars.
At the end of the trip when
your decision-making energy is down
they finally hit you with
the thing you don't even know you need,
but you need it
because you just used all
of your decision-making energy.
Has anyone here ever had the experience
of choosing their wedding registry
in a big department store?
Anyone ever had that, you know,
where they give the telxon gun,
and you walk around yourself
scanning everything.
It's fun in the morning, isn't it?
Hey, what kind of glasses do we want?
Tall ones, short ones,
bright, shiny?
How many do we need?
How many bowls?
How many plates?
How many forks?
How many knives?
How many blankets?
Do we need blankets?
Yeah, by the end of the day,
and my wife and I did this
by the end of the day
we're adding like $300 ice buckets.
We never use an ice bucket.
We don't need an ice bucket
never mind a really fancy one.
Our decision-making energy is gone.
We're making 295 decisions a day,
so to research The Happiness Equation
I interviewed a number of
Fortune 500 CEO's, billionaires,
politicians, world leaders,
best-selling authors,
and I asked them one question.
I said you're a busy, successful person.
How do you make all
the decisions in your day?
How do you create space
because I know your schedule is busy,
and I synthesized the results
from all their surveys into
one drawing I made for you today.
My drawing suggests that
every decision you make
takes a certain amount of time,
and it's of a certain importance.
It's either a lot of time,
or it's a little,
doesn't take very long,
and it's either not very important,
or it's a big deal.
Every single decision we make
is on this chart,
so what do we do
with those decisions that
are low time and low importance?
What do the successful people do?
Low time and low importance.
With those decisions your goal is
to automate them,
to automate them.
Remember I told you I was trying
to decide which way
to get to work everyday?
Now I follow the Waze
crowd-sourced traffic app.
I don't think about how
I get to work anymore ever again.
All those decisions,
which street, this street,
left or right here.
I can try to beat the traffic here.
Let's use the radio for this one,
I don't think about.
I took 52 decisions out of my day
with that one change.
A woman came up to me
after one of my speeches,
and said, you know what?
That makes a lot of sense
because for years at work
I was always struggling at lunch.
At my office it was always like
where are you going to go for lunch today?
Do you want to go here?
Hey, who's going to come with us?
Who's going to drive?
What do you want on your sandwich
lettuce, tomato, pickles?
Oh, we got to get back.
It's like so many decisions about lunch.
She's like now we just have
a new policy.
It's called double dinners.
Every dinner I make I make double,
and the doubled amount is my lunch
leftover the next day.
It's not rocket science.
It takes 32 decisions
out of the day for her.
My friend Chad has
Amazon automatic refills
on every single consumable item
in his entire house.
He never thinks about buying
toilet paper again,
or paper towel, or soap, or anything.
Even towels, he's like, yeah,
I figure I use a towel like
once every 1.5 years,
so it auto replenishes.
Every 1.5 years I get a new face towel.
Every single thing is automatic for him.
It's a decision that for him
is low time and low importance.
What can you automate in your life?
Now, what about those decisions that
don't take very long,
but they're really important?
I'm talking about
picking your kids up from daycare.
I'm talking about saying Hi
to your team in the morning.
This is important stuff, people.
You can't just not to do it,
and that's why my model suggests that
you simply have to do it.
It's effectuate.
It's a big word with a small meaning.
It just means Get 'er Done.
Execute, simply effectuate
those decisions.
Now what about the decisions that
are low in importance
that take a lot of time?
These are the ones that
bog us down, right?
These are the checking 147 emails
throughout the day.
It's getting home every night,
and doing a different chore, or errand.
These are the ones that
actually, actually make us sweat,
and this is why I want to tell you
that for decisions that
are not very important,
but are taking a lot of time
our goal is to regulate them.
Find an invisible fence in your life,
and put it around those things,
so they still exist,
but they're only fenced in.
An example of the person doing
the chore everyday after work.
Chores Blitz Sunday.
Now I only do chores
on Chores Blitz Sunday.
My wife and I our address is 276
on our house.
We have something
we invented called 276 Day.
Anything I think should be
improved in the house,
or anything she thinks
should be improved in the house.
This hinge is kind of broken.
That wall needs a bit more paint.
Someone's got to look at
the toilet upstairs, you know,
we just write on our 276 Day chart.
Now, one Saturday morning a month
from nine to 12
we have it on both of our calendars
for the next 12 months we have 276 Day.
All we're doing is all
those little things that built up.
We've regulated it,
and then we don't worry about
those things for the rest of the month.
It's the same as people that have
created an email window.
I only answer emails nine to 10 a.m.
Four to five p.m.
Guess what?
From 10 to four I'm email free, right?
You regulate it to a part of the day.
Guess what happens when you automate,
effectuate, and regulate your decisions?
You actually have time to debate
the ones that matter.
You actually have time to
think about, to chew on,
to wrestle with
to where am I going to be,
who am I going to be with,
where am I going to go.
All those things that matter
that affect our lives
more than anything else
you can now give them
the time and the energy they deserve
to properly debate them.
- So, Neil, thank you so much
for sharing all these great 10 tips.
I really appreciate it.
Since I have you here
live in person, in studio
I'm curious if you could
share for my audience
a bonus 11th rule?
- The bonus 11th rule.
Here's one for you.
We all have contracts
for our work lives,
employment contracts,
performance contracts.
My bonus tip is you need
a contract for your personal life,
so my wife Leslie and I have
a personal contract it dictates to.
I'll tell you the bullet points.
The number of nights I'm away per year.
The number of nights I'm away per month.
Every week I have an NNO,
a Neil's Night Out,
and every week she's got
an LNO, a Leslie's Night Out.
You laugh, but you know what?
That dinner I have with a buddy,
or that squash game
I'm playing with a friend
with no worries about missing
the time with my wife and my kids
makes me a better dad it really does.
It makes me a better husband,
and I'm not guilty, also,
because I know she's got a day, too.
Our fourth bullet point is that
every weekend, two days,
we have one day
of the two that's just our family
just to kind of, you know,
incubate, have that family time,
and those four bullet points
like the time I'm going to be away
are nights out,
and the time together on weekends
helps me have a bit of
a personal contract that if I break it,
someone that travels a lot,
then I know the next weekend,
or the next week
I got to make it up again.
I think having a personal contract
is just as important
as having an employment contract.
- Is this covered in your book?
- It's not, it's bonus just for
Evan Carmichael's YouTube channel.
It's something that you know what?
I've been talking a lot about recently,
and I'm getting a reaction to it,
and I'm thinking it's something
I need to write something new about
on this topic because it's something
I've been doing for years.
I had a boss when I worked at
Walmart for a decade who said
every time you take a new job
we give you a work contract.
You travel more, you make more money,
you work more hours,
but you don't go home and say,
hey, what does this mean for
number of dinners at home?
What does this mean for
number of weekends away?
Write those things that are home, too,
so that you don't apply
stress and pressure on one system
in exchange for the other.
Because I started doing that for work
then as I became an entrepreneur,
as I'm starting to write,
and speak full-time
it became natural for me
to write this document out
in my personal life, too.
- How do you decide how much of it
you do yourself
because some of them are personal,
and then how much you're bringing
to do as a joy exercise with your wife?
- The way I think about it is
yes, I'm an entrepreneur.
I am writing, I am speaking.
I'm trying to share these messages
about positivity around the world.
I believe that I am working
to increase happiness in organizations,
and what I'm passionate about,
but I am living inside a system that
I love with my wife, with my children
that is as or more important to me,
and that system has to be healthy,
it has to be functional.
It has to have great food,
great dinners, great love,
great vacations.
If I'm being irresponsible to that
system what's the point?
It's all through conversation.
It's all through organic.
You write out what works for you
I shared the travel, the time together,
the nights out for energy
because that's what works for us.
You could have your own things.
It could be about exercise.
It could be about personal vacation.
It could be about, you know,
whatever works for you.
I just think that
having that personal contract
is something that we don't have
enough as entrepreneurs
in the back of our minds
as we're living these busy hectic lives.
We're constantly trading off
our personal for work
when there should be two contracts.
- How often are you
revisiting those contracts?
- About once a year,
about once a year
because it exists on paper,
and you actually write it out,
and you sign it.
- Wow, it's a serious contract.
- Oh, it's a real contract.
- Okay.
- That's why it comes to life is
because you're putting ink on paper here.
Not quite blood on paper,
but it's like pretty serious,
but if you break it, if you break it
if I don't have an NNO,
and I'm kind of frustrated
I need two the next week
to make up for it.
If we don't have
a day together on the weekend
because there's a birthday party,
and we're seeing our parents,
and you know I'm traveling
for one of the days,
or we have stuff going on
we know we need the full weekend
next week to kind of incubate,
so it creates pressure
on you in a way that I think
is ultimately healthy.
- I loved it,
well, thank you for sharing.
- Thank you for having me.
- So thank you guys
so much for watching.
- We made this video for Jason Fonseca.
Jason, thank you so much.
I hope we get to meet in person one day.
- I'd love to know which one of
Neil's rules you like the most,
and what was the biggest takeaway lesson
that you learned from him
in this video?
Please leave it in the comments below,
and we're going to join in the discussion.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.
- Is this a good use of your time?
(applause)
What is a good use of your time?
Could a conversation that
was just questions be
a good use of your time?
What if the only time
everyone is thinking
is when no one is talking?
What if instead of a TED Talk
we did the first ever TED Listened?
Do we give ourselves enough time
to just stop, ask questions, and think?
What do your best days look like?
Is time you enjoyed wasting
really wasted time?
Do you remember when
summer felt like forever?
How do we live so that
it always feels like forever?
Why do more of us live alone now
compared to any other time
in our species history?
Why have suicide rates globally
recently passed murder rates?
Could it be that
the most dangerous person to you
in the whole world is now
you?
Why do we fight more
with people we love most?
If you live with a partner
does your partner meet all your
social, intellectual,
and physical needs?
What do you need?
How do we stop living in the past,
and in the future?
How do we make right now,
right now feel longer?
Does right now actually exist,
or is it just where the past,
and the future touch each other?
Like why does the year 2000
feel closer than the year 2032?
Do we get to choose what we remember?
How do you want to be remembered?
How will you be remembered?
Or would you choose to
live forever if you could?
Or is death
like that tinfoil backing that
a mirror needs
if we are able to see anything?
How well do you know
your grandparent's grandparents?
How well will your
grandchildren's grandchildren
know or remember you?
Is there something you feel
like you just have to do?
Should you drop everything
you're doing except
the biggest possible thing you can do?
Who invented your shoes?
Who invented your glasses,
your books, your foods, your religion?
Who discovered your city,
your country, your company?
Do we know their name?
Do we know how much they've given us?
What story
idea,
or child of yours
might survive
as a tiny, flickering light
deep in the pitch black darkness of
the millions and million year future
we can't possibly imagine?
What if we're all just baton passers
desperately, frantically,
urgently trying to take
the best of everything we've been given
to give the future
the best of what we got?
Who are you in this with?
How will you measure your life?
What is your baton?
How will you maximize your tiny
short life?
How will you
maximize
your tiny
short
life?
Any questions?
(cheers and applause)